so you're a pro-union yeah
now the problem with the unions in the
United States there's is that they I
don't think that I mean I'm not a
specialist I mean I've been in a couple
unions myself but I'm not a specialist
on unions but it looks like they're
corrupted and they're part of the
professional management of course yeah
they're they're they don't really part
of the camp yeah they're part they're
also bad I know so for you to say you're
Pro uni so so you so again for me Jimmy
I I I but Christian Smalls Union is a
great you know there's lots of unions
there you need unions you definitely
need unions I mean if you don't have you
I mean Jesus Christ they they dude look
at what's happened to the freaking
railroad workers just now they won't
even give them freaking sick days and be
and they have a union and the government
comes in and crushes their Union because
they were going to win that strike and
that's why that Governor that government
had to do that and that's real fascism
by the way if you would because I I
generally don't have the answer on
unions I don't think it's all good or
all bad if you could have this
discussion what are the pros and cons of
unions you probably are going to take
the cons perspective no so okay so that
my opinion okay is these things start
with good intentions
but this is the challenge of me and when
you mentioned the lady earlier and then
Vinnie said should they have their own
money and he said well she doesn't have
money but I don't think she can be
bought let me tell you okay and I'll
give you an analogy maybe this will make
sense to you
are you married yeah how long you've
been married
uh 10 12 13 years okay so were you good
with the ladies when you were younger
I'm assuming you were because you're
good with uh you can talk I I had some
girlfriends okay but you you weren't shy
amongst girls yeah okay so I want you to
think about this here uh so imagine if a
guy is not good with girls okay and he's
only been with one his entire life and
he's now 35 and he's not married and but
he's only been with one okay he's just
horrible with girls
but all of a sudden at 35
you know he's now married and he's got a
couple kids and now he becomes Super
Famous and he starts making a lot of
money
and he becomes the best whatever you
know coder at his company and he joins
Snapchat and there's an exit and he
makes 35 million dollars okay
so all the girls that were working at
Snapchat now are coming up to him oh my
God Bobby you're such a great coder man
I love can we go for a drink he's like
I've never had this experience before
damn one [__] two oh my God three that
was cool dude left and right okay if
you're a guy if you've never had play
then all of a sudden you get a lot of
attention you don't know how to handle
it that's correct okay the same to me
goes with money
if you're a politician you've never made
money you become a politician and you
all of a sudden want to do the right
thing then Pfizer knocks on the door
most of the time you're for sale okay if
you're a union worker you're creating
the union for the right reasons then the
people with money show up and say hey Mr
uh uh Jimmy gaffa or whatever your name
is okay hey you know or this Union
Leader we got this leading such and such
here's what we're going to do we think
you're underpaid
okay let's strike up a deal and we're
willing to do XYZ for you but we'll do
this and we'll give you more power and
you'll be locked in for 10 years 15
years with this position but we'll give
you XYZ money that's the problem what a
lot of these politicians and union
leaders they start off with good and
then therefore sell because they've
never experienced real money before what
do you think well I don't I I I've seen
it happen right so I think there's a lot
of Truth to what you're saying for sure
uh we've seen it happen I don't know
what it is like like we just saw uh
uh they get booked like for instance I
I've focused on the squad right uh
because those are supposed to be the
people who don't take corporate money
they're supposed to be the people you
know standing up to the establishment
inside government they're not doing it
and so but they get book deals right
like Corey Bush just got a book deal I
think she's you know I don't know how
many tens of thousands of dollars she
got for that but she probably sold two
books
so I mean that's how they get people so
you're right right so they do get people
um but I think there are people who
could stand up against it I think RFK
stood up against it there you go the the
Forerunner story of pain and
perseverance in America was released on
October 4th the publisher paid Bush and
anti-police socialists who stoked BLM
rights in 2020 in advance of fifty
thousand dollars Bush's financials
disclosure reports show Cory bush wow
and it sold 729 copies in its first week
crushing it
fifty thousand we might have just helped
her sell a couple more copies
of Steel for 7.29 that's a lot of money
I've never written a book and that's a
lot of money I wrote a book I got a book
deal and might had a great manager at
the time so he knew how to get me a good
deal and I think I got the last good
deal you could get without being super
famous so my um my manager at the time
was this guy Alex Murray he's a great
manager and he got me I don't know he he
worked it out he got me twenty thousand
dollar advance for my book I could
believe it I was like that's amazing man
because I don't I don't know how to
write a book I can't even read yeah
you're like I don't even know
imagine book comes out 367 uh spelling
errors in here but it's awesome you know
it's awesome book so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]